hennig es gerade schon gesagt sie
fordern schwere waffen das ist seit
wochen seit monaten ihre forderung keine
einzige schwere waffe hat deutschland
bisher in die ukraine geliefert tragen
wir alle hier mit am tisch damit eine
verantwortung auch dafür für viele tote
in ihrem land so sehen dass meine
landsleute und ich glaube dass auch die
deutschen sich gedanken machen sollten
ob sie tatsächlich bereit sind auch
diese schuld auf sich zu laden denn
dieser krieg wird früher oder schneller
vorbei sein und dann stellt sich die
frage wer war auf unserer seite und wer
hat nur zugesehen und es gibt keine
zwischentöne es gibt nur schwarz und
weiß und da muss man sich entscheiden
und nicht nur sagen nicht nur
versprechen was wir hören sondern auch
wirklich tun und liefern und deswegen
davon hängt ab wie viele ukraine nicht
sterben müssen er schuld sind sie bereit
er schuld diese schuld auf sich zu laden
wie henning gerade sagt oder können sie
immer offen ins gesicht sagen warum sie
dagegen sind gegen neue lieferung von
waffen vermelden ich bin ein wirklicher
fan wie sie irland in unserem land
vertreten aber ich bin auch ein bürger
dieses landes das müssen sie einfach
verstehen
und ich hab das letzte wort von unserer
kanzlerin immer noch in den ohren
bei olaf scholz da kann ich ruhig
schlafen sie beide wurden von ihnen sehr
kräftig attackiert ich finde das passt
nicht zu unserem gespräch aber laden sie
diese wenig sagt schult auf sicher
schuld wenn sie jetzt den kanzler ganz
offen auffordern das sein zu lassen mit
lieferungen schwerer waffen deshalb
völlig blödsinnig dieser dieses argument
ist völlig aus dem von irgendwoher
gegriffen kein deutscher trägt schuld
daran was in der ukraine geschieht
entschuldigen sie bitte dass es so eine
unmögliche behauptung dass hier
aufzustellen in einer öffentlichen
sendung wir deutsche haben andere schuld
noch zu verteidigen von unserer
generation zu sehr ich übrigens fast
schon gehört ich bin in dieser stadt den
trümmern aufgewachsen ich habe die
stalin orgel noch in erinnerung ich war
ein prima kind berlin sah so aus wie die
bilder die man jetzt hier von der
ukraine zeigt aber ich bin dagegen mit
waffen zu töten er rufe da bin ich
wirklich dagegen herr hofreiter sie
sagen wenn man sich als pazifist
versteht muss man jetzt das gegenteil
von dem tun was herr schuld gerade sagt
dann muss man engagiert sein muss man
waffen liefern ich habe mich erstens nie
als pazifist verstanden und des weiteren
gibt es bei uns grünen in dem bereich
einfach unterschiedliche wurzeln auf der
einen seite die friedensbewegung und auf
der anderen seite aber was mg ferrari
schuld hier ein sehr menschenrechte und
das ist ja total vereinfacht gesagt denn
die ukraine hat er den krieg nicht
angefangen
die ukraine hat sich ja nicht ausgesucht
sich wehren zu müssen und es geht hier
nicht darum zu sagen ja waffen liefert
tötet sondern die russische armee tötet
sie morden foltern sie vergewaltigt und
wenn man dann sagt man unterstützt das
opfer nicht dann ist das schlichtweg
unterlassene hilfeleistung und nicht
pazifismus sondern pazifismus ist wenn
man sich für sich selbst entscheiden
dass man sich nicht wert sei aber das
opfer im stich zu lassen ist unterlassen
sagt der grüne bundestagsabgeordnete
anton hofreiter sie kannte schon
vorgestellt herrmann als ex grüne und
sie werfen ihm dürfen den grünen jetzt
vorkriegs stürme hey ich bin schon
jemand über die heftigkeit die grünen
nach vorne marschieren und
verschiedene panzer sorgen beim namen
kennen und so weiter das ist neu
überraschend ich erinnere mich noch als
wir die situation hatten mit dem kosovo
ende der 90er jahre da waren wir gerade
frisch an die regierung gekommen unter
kanzler schröder und in dieser zeit
stand auch die frage und ich bin keine
pazifisten nie gewesen und trotzdem
haben wir ja ein viertel unserer
mitglieder verloren in der zeit also
dann entschieden haben dass wir beim
kosovo unterstützung leisten das ist
dabei kein krieg so wir hatten ja schon
klick auf europäischen boden vor in den
letzten drei sind überzeugt dass nicht
wenn er hoch weiterhin sagen mensch
gerade weil wir
ebenso chancen haben dürfte wird doch
die und mehr das volk von den argumenten
sich auf die amerikaner die seit 2014 ja
sehr viel unterstützung geleistet haben
mit der ukraine die auch waffen
stationiert haben die waffen geliefert
haben die ausbildung gemacht haben die
amerikaner haben derweil die dato keine
einstimmigkeit erreichen konnte von sich
aus die ukraine nach der krim frage
sorgen in angriff kinder mutter
unterstützt ich habe das ja erlebt ich
habe damals noch diskutiert mit würden
von grün wo ich sage das kann doch nicht
sein dass die russen die krim
annektieren das geht nicht und so weiter
das ist völkerrechtlich völlig daneben
war kam aus den grünen reihen oft auch
vielleicht auch von bestimmten leuten
nur na ja nee das ist ja nun muss man
sehen die russen usw ich sage das wird
aber ein zankapfel und hab dann 215 in
meinem ersten buch die zukunft wird
anders deutlich gemacht dass ich davon
ausgehe dass die mauer die deutschen
niedergerissen haben leider in der
ukraine wieder errichtet werden wird und
das können wir wollen und nicht wollen
dass es nicht die frage sondern es ist
vielleicht ein historischer gang der
dinge weil man bei der krim eben nichts
gemacht hat frau lindemann sie sind in
schwedt beruflich in der raffinerie auf
die im moment alle deutschen ja gucken
müssten dort spielt sich gerade er
möglicherweise in drama ab aufgrund der
sanktionen gegenüber putin werden dort
sehr viele arbeitsplätze voraussichtlich
verloren gehen möglicherweise auch ihrer
ihr job hängt seit 27 jahren an dieser
refinery das war ein sicherer
arbeitsplatz dort in schwedt war wie
blicken sie jetzt da drauf haben sie
auch angesichts unserer diskussion hier
den eindruck ja wir diskutieren sehr
viel über die ukraine seit vielen wochen
aber vergessen so ein bisschen ja auf
unsere wirtschaft zu jobs auf unseren
wohlstand zu schauen erklärt feierten
die leute schon seit ein paar jahren
dass wir immer nur ins ausland gucken
und unser land irgendwie so ein bisschen
aus den augen verlieren so braucht die
renten und die ganzen anderen sachen die
kinder sowieso ich finde deutschland ein
kinderfreundliches land geworden in
meinen augen kann ja nur von mir reden
ja und jetzt sehr groß so dass das nicht
unser krieg es tut mir leid für die
sachen die da passieren und das der
leute sterben aber die sind ja schon
vorher gestorben da hat ja der krieg
schon 2014 begonnen und nicht erst jetzt
herr hofreiter nicht unser krieg das ist
etwas was man
mein eindruck ist zunehmend auf der
straße hört und zunehmend mit längerem
verlauf dieses krieges ausgerechnet hier
die kriegsmüdigkeit während diese
kriegsmüdigkeit offenbar in der ukraine
nach wie vor nicht vorhanden ist die
menschen sind tapfer die halten weiter
durch aber bei uns kommt diese
kriegsmüdigkeit
ich weiß nicht ob sie wirklich kommt
nicht meiner beobachtung nach sehen
viele leute eine große verantwortung und
würden sich wünschen dass deutschland
mehr tut aber man darf einzel vergessen
wir importieren immer noch große mengen
energie aus russland und überweisen tag
für tag millionen von euro nach russland
mit dem dieser krieg finanziert wird und
damit sozusagen ist es auch über die
raffinerie von dann auch über diese
raffinerien mann und natürlich ist es
bitter wenn man ein wirtschaftlicher
schwierigkeiten kommt und robert habeck
war vor ort bei der raffinerie und
manchmal wenn man von leuten hat den
leuten auch hilfe versprochen sie haben
auch ein hadek direkt sprechen können
und hat den leuten auch hilfen
versprochen sie das überzeugt was seiner
werke sagt nicht ja aber der punkt ist
das mag sie nicht überzeugt haben aber
versetzen sie sich mal in die situation
der menschen in der ukraine die sterben
die waren zum teil ermordet die werden
gefoltert und das was dort passiert was
hier zum teil mit unserem geld und das
finde diese verantwortung kann war nicht
und sie versteht das beherrschen doch 20
kriege auf der ganzen welt und das liegt
der fokus hin auf diesen einen krieg
warum retten sind dann die anderen
länder nicht und die anderen kinder die
da ich weiß ehrlich gesagt wir sehen
eigentlich aber über 10.000 kinder die
jeden tag verhungern auf der welt wo
helfen wir denn da da könnten wir schon
längst helfen haben sie wie sehen hier
gerade noch mal im hintergrund frau
lindemann die bilder von dem besuch von
robert habeck den besuch den anton
hofreiter gerade angesprochen hat den
sie aus nächster nähe erlebt haben wo
sie gerade gesagt habe das hat mich
nicht überzeugt warum nicht überzeugt
nur weil sein plan auf dem papier steht
der funktioniert auf dem papier so wie
ein fußballtrainer seine mannschaft
aufstellt offen auf der tafel
funktioniert hat reichen rennen und
zurück weil sie glauben halt wenn das
wieder leben ins wilbecke sind schweden
wir merken es wirtschaftlich arbeiten
können also wir werden maximal 50
prozent 60 prozent auslastung haben und
guckt sich doch kinder lange an und
diese versprochenen gelder von herrn
lindner der wir angeblich zahlen soll
daran glaube ich können wir in dieser
situation hier an diesem tisch in diesem
moment frau lindemann sagen ihr job ist
im moment leider aus unserer sicht
weniger wichtig als die unterstützung
für die ukraine schauen sie was für die
ukraine zählt ist ob diese solidarität
aus deutschland etwas wert ist rolle ob
sieg ein wenig wert ist und aus unserer
sicht
alleine und öl export und die erst ende
des jahres
eingestellt werden und nur auch
teilweise viel später also deutschland
jeden tag überweist nach russland nur
für
110 millionen euro und dafür könnte man
drei oder vier 100
schützenpanzer noch kaufen pro ein tag
yoga erwartet 100 seit sechs wochen
keine entscheidung vom kanzleramt und
das ist das ist die devise zionismus der
macht die die meinen das gleiche schuld
macht ihnen das ein schlechtes gewissen
sie arbeiten für diese raffinerien steht
die gute arbeitgeber für sie es seit
jahrzehnten und jetzt sagt er wenig ja
aber auch zu recht davon da wird
sozusagen das geld richtung russland
richtung putin gesunken nachdem das ist
ein schlechtes gewissen wenn sie morgens
zur arbeit gehen den spiegel schauen
machte mir nicht aber ein abo kein habe
gesagt als er bei uns war der russland
sozusagen öl auch an andere länder
verkaufen ich mache ja nicht alle mit
bei diesem öl embargo und er kriegt da
viel geld sogar noch mehr geld weil die
ölpreise gerade steigen also er macht
nur gewinnt wir sanktionieren nur uns
den russen gar nicht wir sind die
leidtragenden das ist nicht wahr dass
wir eine kosten haben ja wirklich nicht
in ordnung dass sie das sagen herr
bendix natürlich haben wir erhebliche
kosten alleine schon dadurch dass wir
die flüchtlinge willkommen heißen und
versuchen so gut wie möglich zu
unterstützen
das war ihnen jetzt nicht reichen und
nicht gefallen aber es ist nicht so dass
die deutschen hartherzig sind das ist
nicht wahr die frage die steht ist viel
größer weil die meisten ukrainer kehren
zurück schon längst es sind mehr
menschen die abreise aus diesem land die
zu ihnen kommen und ich glaube dass sie
sich auch gedanken machen sollten über
die gründe wenn ich jetzt diese unter
mir anhöre ich glaube das ist auch klar
wie viele krämer wieso sie keine lust
haben hierzubleiben
sie fühlen sich nicht viel raum nein das
habe ich aber in dresden anders erlebt
die stelle von ihr mit den leuten aber
ich möchte auch folgendes hinweisen sie
fordern aus ihrer sicht was ich
nachvollziehen kann aus ihrer sicht dass
die deutschen eine führende rolle in
europa übernehmen die amag hat es
eigentlich versucht aber die deutschen
wollen sie gerne mit rein verhaften der
situation ist allerdings die dass das
größte europäische land das allerdings
nicht in der eu ist irland ukraine im
krieg liegt mit dem grössten land der
welt und das größte land der welt hat
zwar auch eu-außengrenzen aber die sind
über das landes angegriffen wollen alles
richtig im krieg liegt habe ich gesagt
ja ich habe nicht gesagt dass die
ukraine etwas angegriffen hatte und die
wie die ganze frage der bass und seit
2014 diskutiert wird ist vielleicht ein
anderes feld aber der punkt auf den ich
hinaus will ist deutschland hat sich
überhaupt nicht mit dieser führungsrolle
befasst gedanklich in den ganzen jahren
nach der wiedervereinigung nicht das war
normal ist und was sie jetzt erwarten
ist überhaupt nicht politisch
vorbereitet deswegen finde ich die
kriegsstimmung auch so für befremdlich
das ist eine emotionale moralische
handlich möchte ich aber noch rational
bei hermann razzien ich möchte einfach
wissen was sie gerade gesagt von ihnen
sie haben gesagt zunehmend sind die
menschen die aus der ukraine zu uns
gekommen sind die fühlen sich hier nicht
willkommen das wäre für uns am tisch
tatsächlich beschämt wenn das so wäre
kann ich nicht warum warum nicht
willkommen mr
es ist eine moralische frage wie gesagt
es ist nicht für uns zu beurteilen ob
sie das ob sie uns unterstützen wollen
oder nicht dass ihre entscheidung aber
was ich heute sagen möchte ist der klick
wird vorbei sein hoffentlich früher als
später nach dem waffen- und nach dem
krieg werden viele sich gesagt wir
werden viele sich fragen stellen wer war
auf unserer seite und
darf ich aus wie das ist ja es ist zeit
ausreden nicht daran überhaupt nicht und
ich bin kein fan von von ihren büchern
aber das letzte buch hat glaube ich
einen schönen titel das große egal und
das was sie heute jetzt vortragen ist
genau dasselbe zu treffen das was sie
was ich hier höre ist ein großes egal
von ihrer gegenüber dem chip nicht
geschultert
den titel an ein schneller das ist der
hand er hat den titel und die das
etikett der schönheit versteinert schon
fühlen sich da ertappt dass es dass es
vielleicht nicht ihnen aber ganz vielen
deutschen mittlerweile egal ist was dort
passiert dass man es halt max it nach
dass man halt weg schaut man halt lieber
lieber wieder lustig macht man sagt vier
monate krieg online mit bildern wir
haben dort dies brief in die welt
gesetzt den offenen brief an das war
schon noch mal eins kann man darüber
spricht und wir sind doch auf ihrer
seite wir verstehen doch dass sie sich
verteidigen
aber ich darf sie doch mal ganz direkt
fragen für welche freiheit kämpfen was
ist ihre freiheit die ich kenne die
freiheit in russland ich kenne die
freiheit den usa ich kenne die freiheit
in kairo unter mubarak ich freue mich
frei lassen
sagte premier die
telekom versuchen sie versuchen den
planeten ukraine in deutschland
anzusiedeln
das ist ihre arbeit dann manche dass
deswegen deswegen haben sie ja meine
bewunderung sie haben von uns
aktionskünstlern sehr viel gelernt erst
provozieren sie dann versuchen sie hier
stimmung zu machen und dann behaupten
sie ich sei es schuldig für jeden toten
vielleicht sogar in ihrem land diese
schuldzuweisung das reiterliche sagen
vertreter das heißt unterlassene
hilfeleistung sie helfen und sie tun es
nicht das ist keine entscheidung aber
das stimmt
dass jeder die sie tragen werden ihre
kinder nein nur die eine seite dieser
hass den sie gegen ein anderes land
haben den sie auch hier in deutschland
uns ja fast versuchen zu vermitteln und
diesen amanda aus straubing oder aus
bayern den haben sie ja auch schon in
zentriert aber welcher stelle das muss
man einmal das war ja schon nur noch
welche man kinder während diese junge
frau schuld dass sie hat
anderen kindern ich das versteht gerade
niemand mehr wissen ein mann aus
straubing wir müssen einfach lernen es
gibt soviel zwischen wir jetzt wieder
wunderbare bei ihr müssen wir müssen
noch einmal wir müssen einmal aufklären
hier ist wahnsinn hatte soviel
zwischentöne wo sie sprechen von der
freiheit in russland lag ganz kurz
sicherheit auf der ganzen welt wir sind
nicht immer in der lage aus diesem land
zu berichten aktuell weil es für uns
gefährlich auch war er gesagt ich habe
gesagt die freiheit für die dieses land
die ukraine kämpft sie ist natürlich in
russland total beschnitten ja aber den
usa auch nur auf eine andere art sie
haben sich abhängig gemacht von der usa
was man da sind wir noch nicht so das
hat sehr viel damit zu tun und sie hat
schon mal helfen entschließt weil ich
nicht entschuldigen sie berät wollen es
geht hier um ganz konkrete sache ein
demokratisches land das defizit der hat
ja dessen korruptionsproblem recht ein
demokratisches land ist von einer
diktatur überfallen worden und zwar ohne
jeden grund ja und dieses demokratische
land wehrt sich verzweifelt und dieses
demokratische land fordere ich dass wir
das vernünftig unterstützen und zu
dieser unterstützung gehören angesichts
des imperialen verleumdungs krieges ein
paar dinge dazu fördert also erstens
dazu dass man stärkere sanktionen gegen
russland macht zweitens humanitäre hilfe
drittens entsprechende unterstützung um
die wirtschaft zu stützen und viertens
vernünftige waffenlieferungen damit die
sich wehren können nämlich es ist nicht
damit getan zu sagen der krieg soll
aufhören wenn der aggressor nicht
aufhört dann hilft es nichts dem opfer
und hier sitzt der vertreter der opfer
zu sagen jetzt hört mal auf mit dem
krieg nämlich der hört dann erst auch
wenn der aggressor aufhören